Republicans are in a desperate panic to
suppress an audio recording of the Texas
Speaker of the House talking about a
political hit list which is just ringing
sort of inappropriate or out of touch
given the constant gun violence problems
that we're dealing with in the United
States there is a recording that was
made by a right-wing activist Michael
Sullivan of his meeting with Texas House
Speaker Dennis bond and so understand
this is all right wingers it's a
right-wing activists right-wing Texas
Speaker of the House Sullivan has a pack
and Bannen gave him a hit list of people
to target in the primaries in Texas okay
in the Republican primaries Republicans
have heard the tape and they are doing
everything that they can everything they
can think of everything they can imagine
to stop its release Texas Republican
Steve Toth called it quote damaging and
embarrassing and there's actually two
layers here that we should be talking
about the first layer is this imagery of
a hit list they couldn't be more out of
touch Mitch McConnell's campaign
recently did something similar they
tweeted a picture of a graveyard with
the names of political opponents
including McConnell's primary opponent
rather uh McConnell's general election
challenger Amy McGrath photoshopped onto
headstones they just can't help
themselves
so the violent imagery is issue number
one the second issue is that the
Republicans don't want their own
infighting made public this is a list of
Republicans to target in primaries that
was assembled by Republicans so
obviously for both reasons I want this
thing released I would love to hear this
tape and we should do everything we can
to get it released but then let's zoom
out just a little bit that this is
happening in Texas specifically is
panicking Republicans nationally because
Texas is one of the few single states
that is keeping Republicans in control
nationally if Texas stops being reliably
red and becomes a purple state either
purple in terms of its representation in
Washington DC at the national level or
purple in terms of its internal house of
representatives at some point in the
future
Republicans may really suffer nationally
and potentially even be affected for a
generation if that were to happen so the
Republicans are particularly panicked
because it's Texas now I've talked
before about how the left really cannot
fall for Donald Trump's attempt to
divide and distract for example when we
talked about his fomenting the divide
between Nancy Pelosi and the squad and
pumping up that infighting we don't want
to allow Donald Trump to divide the left
in this way in this case we want this
Republican Texas infighting to grow as
much as possible for the same reason
that it is going to divide them and
potentially hurt them now let me get to
something else
you know how Democrats handle sexual
assault very differently than Republican
Republicans handle sexual assault by
members of their own respective parties
when Anthony Weiner was caught in a
sexting with a with a minor and doing
all sorts of other stuff who on the Left
was defending Weiner I don't remember
anyone defending Weiner when Al Franken
was caught caught Democrats probably
went too far in demanding that he resign
the left is not only different when it
comes to sexual assault by members of
their own party the left is different on
this cover-up stuff and what I mean by
that is if I found out today that Bernie
Sanders or Elizabeth Warren or whoever
had been caught on a recording saying
something disgusting or damaging or
counter to the values that I believe the
left should espouse I would want it
public immediately I would want to hear
it I would want to comment on it and I
would want to get truly problematic
people out of the movement because they
hurt my movement there are enclaves of
this blind worship of the left around
some twenty twenty candidates which I've
talked about I won't name them but most
of the left would not be trying to cover
up something equivalent to this we would
want it out we would want the people
dealt with and we would want to move on
with people that we feel good about they
are really different than us okay I want
to win but I want to win without
stooping to their level
okay so I've said before listen heckling
a politician in public in a non-violent
way this is okay and we've got to be
okay with it
but I don't want to stoop to their
tactics to win even though I do want to
win and that's why it makes this so
complicated
let's hope at least in the interim and
the immediate is that the audio is
released and I will be talking about
this and much more tonight during a live
twitch event at 6:30 p.m. Eastern I hope
you'll join me at twitch.tv slash David
Pakman and we can talk about this or
anything else you want too should be a
great event make sure you're following
me on Twitter at des Pakman and while
you're there follow the david pakman
show on twitter at david pakman show we
will take a quick break and be back with
much more a lot of really good stuff on
today's program if you love learning new
things you probably want to check this
out the david pakman show today is
sponsored by skill share and we're
giving you two entire months of free
access to skills share when you click
the link underneath this video skill
share is a vibrant online learning
community offering more than 25,000
video classes on just about anything you
can think of get better at playing an
instrument learn to use Photoshop how to
edit videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video